sie findet so jeder stunde an jedem tag
im jahr statt und sichert den luftraum
über österreich die luftraumüberwachung
des bundesheeres das bundesheer
unterstützt dabei die zivile
flugsicherung und greift bei
notsituationen mit ihren zur verfügung
stehenden mitteln ein
[Musik]
jährlich erfolgen ca 1,3 millionen
flugbewegungen über österreich
das besondere sämtliche flugbewegungen
über österreich werden rund um die uhr
überwacht doch welche aufgaben werden
konkret übernommen
durch die luftraumüberwachung leistet
das bundesheer einen wesentlichen
beitrag zum schutz der sicherheit von
uns allen wie zum beispiel bei der
wahrung der lufthoheit den schutz von
wichtigen objekten und die abwehr von
gefahren aus der luft um diese aufgaben
zu erfüllen verfügt die
luftraumüberwachung über radaranlagen
und abfangjäger besonders für
großveranstaltungen stehen flieger des
bundesheeres ständig zur verfügung
aus der zentrale in sankt johann im
pongau bekommen die flugzeuge der
luftraumüberwachung anweisungen kommt es
zu unregelmäßigkeiten im flugverkehr
werden die abfangjäger aktiviert um so
schnell wie möglich am ziel zu sein
fliegen sie auch schneller als der
schall die abfangjäger klären durch
sichtkontakte situation die piloten
arbeiten dabei eng mit dem bodenpersonal
zusammen mit einigen nachbarländern
bestehen außerdem abkommen um auf
gefahren noch schneller und
grenzübergreifend reagieren zu können
wenn die situation nicht in der luft
geklärt werden kann wird das ziel zu
einem flughafen begleitet bei dem es für
die weitere abklärung landet
im schnitt kommt es jede woche zu so
einem einsatz flug oft handelt es sich
dabei um luftfahrzeuge die ohne
funkverbindung über österreich flüge
als permanente einsatz aufgabe überwacht
das bundesheer dem österreichischen mit
frauen 24 stunden am tag 365 tage im
jahr
[Musik]
das österreichische bundesheer wir
schützen österreich